a seafood market a virology lab
and a mine deep in the mountains key
events at these places in china could be
crucial to understanding how a small
cluster of coronavirus cases ended up
sweeping the world
because almost a year and a half into
this global health crisis
politicians and scientists are still
debating how it all started
if you're going to look for the origin
of a pandemic you really should start
right away when the clues are fresh
right now that's looking pretty
difficult that's because access to wuhan
has been really limited
until you nail it down definitively
you've always got to keep an open mind
that it might be something else
the main hypothesis is that the virus
originated from bats
jumped to another animal then to us and
the leap to humans might have happened
here
at this market 10 miles away is where
some scientists believe that the virus
may have accidentally leaked from a lab
and both of these spots in wuhan have an
increasingly important connection to one
place
that's over 1 000 miles away in the
mountains of yunnan province
so we visit these key places to break
down what we know about the coronavirus
to understand how the global pandemic
may have started
stop number one the huan on seafood
market december 31st
2019. this is the day the who learned
about a cluster of pneumonia cases in
wuhan
and increasingly the focus was on the
market the complex spans an area that's
the size of nine football fields and has
over 600 stalls
about 10 of those were selling wild
animals like bamboo rats
hedgehogs and hog badgers these
wildlife are raised on farms sometimes
in crowded conditions where it's easy
for animals to spread viruses
back and forth between each other and
the viruses start to mix and match and
can change some wildlife that are
receptive to coronavirus infections are
consumed in china
either for food or used in traditional
medicine these animals
are shipped to urban markets where they
are sold
sometimes live and butchered on site and
all this contact
with live possibly infected animals or
the infected
fresh meat has become a major concern in
recent years
and in wuhan many of the first cases
were either vendors who worked at the
market
or people who are shopped there by
january 1st
chinese authorities shut the place down
well originally chinese authorities did
feel that it possibly came from the one
on market and from
you know wild meat of some sort
about three weeks later scientists in
wuhan and beijing published a pivotal
paper in the medical journal the lancet
this chart shows how some of the early
cases were people who hadn't been at the
market
more than a year later there was new
data to piece together a clearer picture
that's because china allowed a group of
international scientists to come to
wuhan
for several weeks to visit the market
and hospitals
a team from the who that visited china
also learned going through the data that
by mid to late december
the viruses that were infecting people
were genetically different enough that
they knew it wasn't all coming from the
same place
the who said the presence of early cases
not linked to the market
could suggest that it was not the
original source of the outbreak
and increasingly one place the team
visited is at the center of another
hypothesis
the wuhan institute of virology this is
a world-class
institute with high security
laboratories
and does a lot of work with scientists
outside of china
very vibrant collaboration before the
pandemic
they would travel to caves where bats
are known to roost
and take samples and then study them in
their lab these back coronaviruses and
pathogens are catalogued in databases
the researchers used this library of
information to compare it to blood
samples and oral swabs from patients in
wuhan
and about a month after the market was
closed these researchers discovered that
coven 19 had a 96.2
genetic match with the back coronavirus
that the institute had found
back in 2013. scientists around the
world considered this a breakthrough in
the search for coven 19
source because it strongly indicated
that it could have originated in bats
this laboratory studies back
coronaviruses right in buhaan it was an
obvious question could it have escaped
and even
the institute's own researchers asked
that question
and went and did their own research as
questions swirled around a possible
accident at the institute
its top back coronavirus expert said the
virus didn't leak from her labs
and none of its staff have tested
positive for coven 19.
these are not the first times that we've
had a world
exposed to virus as a result of failures
in a chinese
lab last year you know what started out
as a basic scientific question
got politicized with a lot of finger
pointing in china
yet there was no evidence presented
anything interesting and there was also
limited access to data during the whole
lead team's trip to wuhan
one of the stops was the virology
institute they asked questions
and they had a tour but they didn't get
any first-hand look at
databases medical records any sort of
raw data which would have shed light on
whether the virus could have escaped or
not
almost a week later scientists summed up
their findings at a press conference
they said the spillover from an
intermediate host to humans was likely
to
very likely and as for questions
surrounding the lab
the findings suggest that the laboratory
incident hypothesis
is extremely unlikely but later the who
chief said the team didn't sufficiently
examine the lab hypothesis
and called for a fuller probe three
months later after that press conference
a group of leading virologists and
epidemiologists
wrote a letter saying there were no
findings in clear support of either a
natural spillover or lab accident
this group of people is not saying that
they believe it came
from the lab what they're saying is that
there's not enough evidence to rule it
out
scientists investigate hypotheses and
they rule them out one by one
and they said that process hasn't been
able to happen and it needs to happen
china says it's cooperated fully with
the effort to search for coven 19 source
and has urged the who to investigate
early cases in
other countries
and one place that could provide some
new evidence for both hypotheses
yunnan it's china's southwestern most
province and home
to many coronavirus carrying bats and
could set the stage for where the
investigation into the origin of the
virus could go next
it's clearly an area where coronaviruses
are circulating
including coronaviruses that are very
closely related to
sars the epidemic in 2003.
researchers from the wuhan institute of
virology went to yunnan to study large
bat populations inside
caves in these crowded spaces viral
strains can mix together
and become the building blocks of
coronavirus that then jump to humans
and at the same time there are wildlife
farms there
that supply animals to wuhan scientists
say this could explain how a virus from
a bat cave
leapt to an intermediate host then made
its way to the market
there was also a mine in yunnan where
scientists from the institute spent some
time from 2012
onwards it's where six miners who'd been
clearing bat droppings had gotten sick
and developed an unexplained pneumonia
three of them died
so in 2013 scientists from the institute
went to the cave to collect samples from
bats
a virus from one of these samples turned
out to be that 96.2
genetic match that was discovered by the
institute and hailed as a big break
during the early days of the pandemic
it took months for the institute to
reveal that the back coronavirus samples
were from the mine
and that there were sick miners the
failure to describe it more
became kind of a touch point for people
who wanted
more information from the laboratory
about the viruses they do have
and what work they've been doing with
them
then there was another allegation about
the institute that surfaced more than a
year later
what u.s intelligence officials
learned is that there were three
researchers
who became ill enough to seek hospital
care they had symptoms that were like
coveted but the symptoms
like covet are also like flu symptoms
and flu was definitely circulating in
wuhan at that time
four days after the intelligence report
about the sick lab workers
the biden administration ordered a u.s
intelligence inquiry into the two
scenarios
china said the report was untrue
some people don't believe china and say
this has to be a cover-up
others say we just need to verify
that's what we do in science we verify
we look at the data
and reach our own conclusion it really
does boil down to
a question of transparency so for any
progress to be made in the origins of
the virus
it'll ultimately require more data and
fuller access to where it was first
detected
in china